[Applaudissements]
le trafic
[Musique]
sakho 6 disques d'or et vangelis six
cent mille exemplaires vendus cette
chanson tout le monde la connaît très
heureux de vous revoir un petit moment
que vous avez perdu a perdu qu'on vous
avez moins vu jeudi
avec le coup vite c'est sûr ça n'a pas
été évident de continuer à faire mon
métier oui notamment la scène et les
médias je suis resté dans mon sud natal
parce que ce que vous mettez aujourd'hui
justement si vous êtes toujours fait des
concerts plus que jamais chanteuse
puisque j'ai profité des deux années de
provident pour créer mon nouvel album
oui donc est également on va dire que je
suis ambassadrice de la défense animale
d'accord puisque tout récemment je
m'engage après dix ans parce que j'avais
démarré quand même avec eux il ya dix
ans avec les gamelles du coeur et là je
reviens plus récemment pour défendre
donc les animaux abandonnés en refuge
grâce à l'association défense de
l'animal or ça c'est une très belle
pause mais moi ce que je veux savoir
c'est est ce que vous faites pas de quoi
vous vivez aujourd'hui vous faites des
concerts et bien heureusement alors
heureusement toute l'année non mais on
joue bien le coup vide mais sinon depuis
mes 20 ans que j'ai démarré à 20 ans
chaque été je fais à peu près 40
concerts après quarante concerts on a
fait un documentaire sur vous et vous
dites que vous faites est prêt ou et 50
concerts par an et globalement ces 2000
euros le concert dont vous gagnez à peu
près cent mille euros par an plus que
vous dites annoncé un petit peu se
baptiser un c'est vous qui l'avez dire
cent mille euros par an ouais non n'est
pas mon avis mon
oui c'est moins quand c'est moi bonjour
moi mais je suis à l'aise je suis
heureuse et l'argent de toute façon
c'est quoi ce n'est pas ne pas le
bonheur
n'est pas forcément l'essentiel de ma
vie ce que j'aime c'est vraiment me
battre pour ce qui m'est cher
c'est-à-dire les haines mo est sûre j'ai
bien compris ma passion et leur m'en
parler parce qu'aujourd'hui vous voulez
plus qu'on vous appelle eve angeli c'est
ça si possible tu l'as dit beaucoup mais
je ne sais pas
merci c'est toute norme intelligente et
je vais lire ses marques et
pourquoi vous
[Applaudissements]
on a tout changé de prénom moi c'est
benjamin vous avez enlevé l'or j'ai dit
tout simplement parce que c'était quand
même beaucoup associé à une image pas
toujours flatteuses jeu là vous à
laquelle j'ai contribué je le reconnais
et voilà j'avais tout simplement envie
de laisser un petit peu derrière le
superflu et garder l'essentiel est alors
justement vous dites vous dites dans des
interviews qu'on a fait de vous vous
avez fait des mauvais choix parce qu'à
l'époque vous vouliez absolument
absolument habituellement exister
regardez il dans un tourbillon
médiatique f se perd acceptant de se
caricaturer à l'extrême je sortais d'une
émission de télé réalité et à cette
époque là mon propre rendement proposé
plein de projets diverses et variées
c'était pas forcément toujours bien
conseillé malheureusement
ajoutez à ça le fait que tu as peur de
disparaître du jour en main mais tu te
dis si je dis non à ça peut-être que
demain on verra plus donc ça puisse le
fait que j'étais mal conseillés pour
durer dans le temps je prenais tout ce
qu'ont proposé dans l'instant t et je
n'avais pas de vision à long terme
j'étais un petit peu instrumentaliser
cette époque mary menteuse et par qui
les évangélismes qui vous ont rendu si
célèbre finalement si vous ont pas fait
du bien
instrumentalisés par les médias pour
répondre à ta première question est est
ce qu'ils m'ont fait du bien par moments
oui puisque si je continue à être si
populaire dans le coeur de gens aient à
faire des concerts je ne cracherais pas
dans la soupe c'est aussi grâce aux
médias qui ont parlé de moi mais
aujourd'hui j'aimerais qu'on m'invite
pour parler de ma musique en fête et pas
forcément ça tombe bien c'est ce qu'on
va faire aujourd'hui vas-y pas dans
cette émission là mais bientôt c'est
kevin je comprends ce que vous dites
mais l élite b ce que j'ai toujours du
mal à comprendre parfois avec les
artistes c'est que c'est que vous êtes
connu pour quelque chose les gens vous
aiment pour quelque chose et tout d'un
coup c'est un peu comme une star qui
veut pas chanter son tube sur scène et
puis tout d'un coup vous leur dites mais
moi maintenant et mais moi mais je veux
plus qu'on parle de ça mais forcément on
vous a aussi mais pour ça ça vous
pourquoi c'est beau c'est faisable ça
vous blesse comme on parle des
évangélistes le savons est offert de la
ferme célébrités ça me laisse pas mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya toujours un envers
du décor et c'est vrai qu'on m'a quand
même fait passer souvent pour plus bête
que je ne le suis en réalité et on
oublie l'essentiel de ce que j'aime
faire en fait et moi j'ai peut-être pu
me perdre par moment parce que justement
je l'oubliais aussi et aujourd'hui je
suis heureuse de revenir et de me dire
je fais ce que j'aime je chante je
soutiens les animaux parce que si je
peux juste dire c'est quand même deux
cent mille abandon par an les animaux et
il ya trente mille animaux qui chaque
jour à temps de trouver un maître d'armé
de la cause est très peu dire on tient
des choses intelligentes mais vous
pouvez gérer tes voilà deux d'être
futile à 42 ans mais c'est fou de se
voir pendant un instant parce que c'est
intéressant de penser que vous étiez
futile avant parce que vous parliez pas
forcément d'une cause animale ou pages à
présent que le passé vous a fait du mal
notamment va parler aussi parce que je
sais que vous avez changé de marie vous
vous êtes mariés et aujourd'hui vous
voulez pas qu'on filme votre mari vous
voulez pas le montrer voulais pas
montrer votre vie privée va pas dans
l'ain instant va recevoir également
aussi texte on fera un dossier sur
johnny hallyday bref restez bien avec
lui a tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
single
8 vangjeli
oui je les écris c'est à qui elle a
écrit aussi là où la mélodie ouais parce
que reste comme je disais du coup dès
lors si rose en attend pas forcément
dans la chanson quand même si je sais
moi qui est bon en fait pour récolter
plus tard des bonnes secondes c'est très
positif c'est une balade oui j'ai une
question à poser son auto produit ses
chansons comme ça est ce qu'on y
diffusant les radios parce que j'ai
jamais entendu cette chanson parle alors
c'est normal que tu ai pas entendu j'ai
même pas encore tourné le clip non donc
en fait le clip fait de tournée le 8
mars dans le sud de la france où je
réside et ensuite j'espère bien
évidemment que ça va donner envie aux
médias de diffuser le clip et pourquoi
pas d'un second temps je sais que je
suis plus télévisuelle que radiophonique
à l'heure actuelle donc débouté la
vérité forcément tu sais ma ti les
jantes un vide c'est parce qu'ils
veulent un évangélisme ils veulent la
barque c'est drôle la flotte sur l'eau
ils veulent enfin tibet le passé mais le
vrai le méthane a sorti un bouquin toi
même les évangélismes et c'est vrai
quand on pensait à toiser toujours
est-ce qu'elle joue l'idiote et c'est un
génie ou est ce qu'elle est la plus
idiote et c'est génial de gagner de
l'argent avec ça mais c'est vrai que tu
laisses mêmes toi même planer le doute
et tu sais que très bien que les c'est
ce que vont vouloir les journalistes
c'est pour ça qu'ils vont te recevoir et
que si tu arrives à leurs 10 ans
maintenant je veux plus qu'on appelle à
ben jeddi jeu plus comme parle des
populismes j'ai un nouvel album qui est
un peu perché tout ça tu savais de plus
compliqué tu t'en doutes quand même non
disons que je pense pas puisque
aujourd'hui j'ai l'honneur d'être ici et
pourtant qu'il savait très bien que mon
album s'appelait eve oui et je voulais
un revirement d'image absolument mais a
tout de même invité c'est vrai oui donc
je pense que ce sera pareil avec les
gens intelligents comme vous la donner
avec cintra je n'irai pas c'est parfait
on a un extrait justement où on est en
train de filmer chez toi et on te
demande pas être ta vie privée et tu
caches tout regarde
mon mari m'a offert lui-même cette
balançoire en fait qu'il a réalisée de
ses mains donc c'est une belle
symbolique pour moi qui ai toujours vu
la balançoire com
une élévation de l'esprit mariage à la
base j'étais pas pour mais dans la vie
c'est comme tout c'est une question de
rencontres faut pas dire fontaine je ne
boirai pas de ton eau faut juste trouver
la bonne fontaine
et j'ai eu cette chance en fait c'est
que l'homme de ma vie n'avait aucun
aucun a priori sur qui j'étais
maintenant pour préserver les jolies
choses que l'on a dans la vie il faut
tout simplement les garder secrète pour
bas que comme on dit tout simplement
pour vivre heureux vivons cachés et
l'ipad vous voulez devenir la nouvelle
un peu un peu dans la benne un peu de
clair le chenil de belle clara luciani
c'est vrai ça disons que je suis fan de
clara luciani son univers de l'artiste
qu'elle est elle également du sud de la
france avoue que c'est mon péché mignon
parce que je suis né à sète je suis une
réserviste donc c'est surtout je suis
fan en fait cher numérisé est et alep
dont on connaissait en connaissez votre
mari à l'époque qui s'appelait
aussi
s'est mariée mais j'ai vécu douala temps
il se révèle l'histoire vous ai même
fait une téléréalité ensemble ah oui sur
une télé ryter ensemble voilà justement
est aujourd'hui bas quand on vous a
demandé parce qu'on avait films et
documentaires vous ai dit je veux pas
montrer mon mari je montrais aucune
photo je ne veux rien montrer ma vie
privée mais pourquoi vous en avait tant
souffert disons que les gens changent
j'avais 20 ans à les 25 maximum
aujourd'hui on est 40 j'ai envie d'être
heureuse et comment le sait c'est un
cliché mais pour vivre heureux vivons
cachés au moins la vie privée après
j'aime mon public j'aime chanter pour
eux et je sais que ça ça restera
toujours un plaisir d'être médiatisé
pour les belles choses en fait pour le
reste les médias peuvent salir un petit
peu et j'en ai souffert en effet dans
mon passé avec certaines relations
privées qui ont pris fin parce que ça a
été dans la presse people a regretté
cette mission de télé rites et que vous
avez fait de la l'époque ouais non non
non moi je suis pas du genre à regretter
mais je suis du genre à ne pas
reproduire les erreurs parce que
justement je pense à très intelligente
d'accord on la wii joué pour quelques
soins est vendu à m elle est la reine de
la ce et elle sera notre ancien manège
c'est magnifique
j'ai été dirigé lui d'accord mais c'est
gentil merci j'ai lu j'ai lu comme quoi
vous donner des cours de chant oui ou
merde et comme quoi j'aurais album était
financé une partie par vaux par vos fans
et ils devraient enfin quelqu'un de
documenter annoncé sinon ses besoins de
l'aven à question
là c'est vrai merci ça va sortir sur
ulule c'est un site participatif
vous connaissez tout ça sera lancé le 21
mars et ça finira le 6 mai donc voilà
les gens qui veulent
aller en contrepartie
un dîner un duo sur scène avec moi à ses
besoins quoi juste donné en fait c'est
de recevoir ses et nommé pour école une
dernière question de divine oui une
toute dernière question alors moi je
respecte totalement votre parcours sable
ça nous fait penser un peu quand même à
nabila qui aujourd'hui n'est pas réduite
à jeter de meuf et a pas de shampooing
moi je moi je respecte totalement mais
ce que vous disiez qui était très
touchant également dans le documentaire
signé matt prod c'est qu'à l'époque vous
souffriez de crise d'abord à faux
billets de paranoïa voudrais savoir où
vous en étiez ce que vous en étiez guéri
est-ce que ça allait venir aujourd'hui
alors paranoïa c'est un mot un peu gros
quand même si c'est une vraie maladie
mais agoraphobie oui et encore
aujourd'hui comme je le disais tout à
l'heure à laurent je suis une anxieuse
de nature j'ai besoin d'avoir un petite
bouteille d'eau là en bas vous la voyez
pas les cacher j'ai mon éventail si je
manque d'air je suis une grande anxieuse
ans est vrai que
des fois je peux pas nerveuse et je peux
dire plein de choses qui vont plus vite
en fait c'est mes émotions qui parle et
en aucun cas c'est de la bêtise c'est
vraiment j'aime quand on est hyper
émotif c'est le coeur qui parle avant la
raison plouzané souffert ça de vous
pensez que les gens ont pensé pendant
longtemps vous étiez idiote oui oui et
encore aujourd'hui les gens n'aient
encore aujourd'hui à tous heureusement
mais je me dis que c'est des gens bêtes
qu'ils ne le pensent et les gens
intelligents réfléchir et je suis désolé
juste question rapidement et ses yeux la
radio du ca taxes on se souvient que tu
as fait on va s'gêner week after laurent
ruquier j'étais très très bien dedans
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui t'a
qui donne envie de 2,2 j'aimerais
retourner dedans ou la radio j'adore
honnêtement parce que on se sent moins
vu on se sent forcément plus cacher
c'est pas filmer je préfère la radio à
la santé pour tous les cas tu réponds
rien bongo question tapis tellement
envie qu'on te vois-tu turckheim
beaucoup souffert on entend quand même
tout ça quand même est à tort tu très
joli et j'espère qu'on va te voir
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]